hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to monstrum a roguelike
randomized indie horror game that is
supposed to be terrifying and awesome
and that's not just me sing this game is
available right now on Steam for $15
which is a little bit pricey for an
indie horror game but it's rated at very
positive or at least I think it is
either way it's somewhat positive but
then again I played these indie horror
games on Steam before and they turn out
to be steaming piles of crap I am so
sorry that was literally the worst joke
I've ever made in my life let's just
move on to the game so I don't have to
embarrass myself
oh wait that's still gonna happen ugh my
head is killing me from that joke what's
going on where am I find out where I is
so I loaded up this game before oh and
apparently you're in a room filled with
boxes and then you have to step through
this weird Locker into the other room
because it was shoved in the front of
the doorframe I'm assuming to hide
myself from whatever monsters lie within
this ship so we are on a ship I do know
that then again I have not explored all
that much I was only trying to see if
the that was a bed before like no joke
this shows how randomized is that was a
bed the last time I walked in here then
again I don't know how randomized this
could be not randomized at all and I'm
just being a jackass of course that's no
Billy different from anybody normal
Let's Plays but let's get to it hold
left shift to run I haven't needed to do
that yet because I haven't seen any
monsters yet so the main objective is
your oh I didn't even uh I totally
forgot this there was a note on the
ground in there that I picked up before
and there's actually the note I picked
up from the last time I loaded up this
game check off in Wilson I think
something's gone seriously wrong I
haven't seen another pair in hours they
went to investigate the engine but no
one's come back there's definitely a
fire I can smell them burning the bodies
or the engines I don't want to make any
noise by banging the door I heard the
dumbass Fred yelling and then he just
cut off if you wake up and find this I'm
making for the portside balcony to use a
life raft I'm leaving I know you're sick
but we have to get off this ship if you
arrive in the next hour I'll be waiting
Ellis Hart loved Ellis if Ellis was
smart he would have run off without me
otherwise he's probably dead this is the
other note that I picked up Brett the
captain sent me the details on check on
Wilson they were scalded by the tower
according to them the water
did you hear that according to them
where was I
the Walters stop for a second then
blasted out steam I'm giving you a
repair job some of the guys reported a
burning smell down near the boiler two
days back when I checked it out there
was nothing but it might be a good place
to start Fred fred is dead
Freddy's okay that wasn't me
that was not me alright we're not we're
off to a great start on this game okay
so basically you're just wandering from
place to place trying to find okay
that's new is that Fred is it is that
Fred up there Fred I thought you were
dead stop banging around you know you're
gonna give yourself
okay what the hell he was starving
around above me how did he get in the
same floor as me I guess we all just
said hello to the monster holy hell
Jesus he came out of nowhere
what was I doing I was yelling probably
my microphone is connected to the game
and they can all hear me like huh
there's that dumbass over there I don't
even know what my name is Oh back here
again let's see if it changed again he
does something else pick up the
flashlight OOP yeah see I told you it
was a bed before I wasn't lying and
that's where the note I don't know if I
picked that up this time but I got a
fuse which I can only assume is supposed
to be replacing some electronics here so
I totally snuck up on me like a tick bag
not that he was really sneaking up that
much cuz he was kind of stomping around
making a lot of noise really announcing
himself would be hosting another glow
stick
it's my glow stick heaven the note that
I read like I knew that I was on a ship
and I'm supposed to get off because of
the light showed you this ooh who can I
dive headfirst in the ocean trust my
life with the sharks hey they like me
they really like me okay so it's
obviously a big-ass cargo ship where's
that lifeboat the guy was talking about
there's got to be a way to get up there
because I imagine if I can get up there
that's gonna help me because it's
probably some use Oh what am i doing I I
saw a staircase I'm an idiot
I probably shouldn't run all that much
just saying because it's probably going
to lead to something eating my face
again snapping my neck like a twig and
then throwing me over bard okay so if I
go up I should be able to get to the
cabin of the cargo ship
oh crap
Oh God that's making noise why is that a
thing why are the security systems still
working here this is security
can I turn off the security system for a
minute probably get a cup smashable
oh well I'm just making all the noise in
the world bleeding all of the monsters
come nibble a little bit bedroom okay
all right hang up no not again turn up
like you ain't gonna give me I shouldn't
have smashed that bottle well that
wasn't a good sound what the hell
happened there someone come to say hi to
me oh holy crap I'm having the worst
luck and by that I mean I'm just stupid
I wonder if I need to be secret smash or
if I should look at this camera
rawr goddammit go away man honey I need
to do something I think this is the fuse
box yeah fuse so if I put no oh ah there
are some fuse box and scattered around
here maybe if I find some fuses I can
power them up because that's probably a
good thing make more nose make more
light noise night lows lag loo I can't
speak English okay okay why did I get
the clothes to go haha oh cool these are
working I'll be able to see everything
okay so this helped this helps me how
they look like they're all the same
thing yeah these are all the same thing
there's a bunch of baloney you above me
or below me I can't tell like okay
that's much better
and by much better I mean only
marginally better okay here's a map okay
damn this place is big so right now I'm
on the crew deck which when I went
outside I saw down to that way so I need
I should keep moving I shouldn't stand
in one place should I who was this thank
you
when you're gonna need a fire
extinguisher okay more glow sticks glow
sticks all right so plenty of glow
sticks aren't what is all of this is any
of this useful to me can I do anything
with any of this no all right
how am I supposed to do that what am I
supposed to do
okay so this helps me how drill updated
where am I Oh a ship you just you only
discovered now that you were on a ship
you were looking out the ocean how the
hell did I end up here that must be some
way out of this I better look around
fine look around some more okay I found
out where I was so what does that mean
for me escape route life rafts someone
seems to have tried to escape using this
Alice but it looks like something went
wrong they died I should have a closer
look at it inspect life raft well how
how close do you want me to get
okay I don't think he's coming after me
yeah I'm look I'm standing right on top
of it how much do you want yo oh I need
to use button it okay so what does that
mean see the raft is torn and deflated
but it looks fixable I'll need to use a
crane to lower it into the water power
the crane I did that apparently seal the
tears replace cranes chain inflate the
raft okay so I need a chain and need
like duct tape or something and I need
like an air compressor to be able to
fill this up and get this done okay
that's totally doable I have an
objective I know what I need to do
that's quiet that's nice and quiet there
oh did not know that I needed to hold
that down okay so once okay so this
needs a new chain here to be able to
lift it I need to inflate it and I need
to get done ooh he's got a light on his
face he's got a lady face he's got a
face like why did you have a face like I
should have noted that last time he was
coming up to me he got eventually
ah am I going into a corner I was alone
all this not what I wanted he's it
coming after me
he's it coming he's a he's a hidey hidey
hole coming okay so I just need to get
back down onto the level because I
thought I probably need to go like to
the cargo hold or something to be able
to find the supplies I need this looks
like the residential area so there's got
to be like a maintenance deck or
something like that which would have the
tools necessary to be able to do this
stuff goody goody gumdrops I'm making
progress everybody's so proud of me
well why don't I just use this thing
this looks useful part broken there
appears to be a functional helicopter on
the main deck it needs fuel but maybe
this could be a means of escape keys cut
restraint cable find pump equipment well
how the hell am I gonna find keys on a
giant boat the rest of those seem
relatively easy probably why that one's
actually probably a very hard escape
route I don't even know if I know how to
fly a helicopter how could I do that
I think the life raft is still my best
bet okay so I think this leads down to
the cargo hold which is probably allow
me to find some of the supplies that I'm
gonna need I gotta admit
it's actually kind of nerve-wracking I
mean part of it is the element of the
unknown below steam part of it is the
element of the unknown I literally don't
know what to expect from this game and
that's always cool and I see it's very
well made there's a lot of detail in the
game which when you play in the horror
games and that's probably why it kind of
justifies the price tag a little bit
whoa because it actually has a good bit
of production quality in the game which
is something that's not often seen in
the indie horror world I mean the indie
game world is still I mean even though
it's been around for a few years in the
game world in all aspects not just
horror is still in its infancy like
things are still being explored there's
no rules nothing is set in stone is that
bad for me is that gonna be bad for me
steam my old nemesis is just the same
thing what is all this crap I mean
obviously whoa what are those oh they're
masks okay ah can I space up my space up
please thank you I just know I'm gonna
pull myself up and there's gonna be a
monster staring at me in the face uh-oh
fuel fuel I got fuel holy hell that's
gonna help me I need to fuel up the
helicopter I don't need to fuel up the
life raft if not unless I want to
inflate it with more flammable stuff
explode in a big fire show out on the
middle of the Pacific Ocean there's
another battery but I don't think I need
another one there's another battery but
I don't think I need another one there's
oh wait what is it
okay um just I don't want it I don't
wanna smash it yeah didn't mean to is
that please tell me that's an air-pump
welding kit welding kit where in the
world am I gonna need a welding kit let
me just weld my raft together
so I don't know where I popped out
that's a bad side I'm out of here baby
whoo I'm going up I'm going up I'm going
up I'm going up I'm out here I'm out of
here
what is this get over here wait a minute
what the hell did I somehow make it all
the way to the I made it all the way to
the crew deck all these doors are open
I've been here no wonder he's here I
came to him hidden come to me oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh go go what are you doing go oh
Jesus Oh goddamnit I gotta close one of
these to add
possessing what the hell just happened
ah I died to steam I died to steam I
died to steam what the hell why you do
that to me game god dammit I was running
for my life what am I supposed to stop
for the steam okay so starting fresh in
the end I did not get all that far I
found a few things but nothing
specifically to what I needed
I need duct tape an air pump or
something along those lines maybe I
could like jury-rigged a fire
extinguisher to try to inflate that raft
but either way I know what I need to do
I think the raft is the best bet it
seemed like the easiest amount of things
to collect so that's what I'm gonna be
going for so let me go down first
because there was a lot more items in
the cargo hold the bag
don't be summoning that monster I just
got away from him you bastard don't do
that to me I'm trying to survive my
heart is really going pounded that's not
English was where I said do hahaha I'm
out I'll go red give me you goodies I'm
a looter I'm gonna loot all your [ __ ]
give me your [ __ ] oh I found the beer
kegs perfect how those alien bastards
won't get him them from me god damn it
I can't find anything but the cargo hold
alright give me that [ __ ] what's that
I'll pump I'll pump it up pump Oh
pump it up so Gord okay I'm gonna dump
these for now cuz I found a radio wait
why would I want a radio is that any
good to me uh I'm gonna abandon the sub
stuff I don't think the sub is gonna be
my avenue but that is goddamn pump
perfect perfect perfect Peter Piper
picked a pakka
perfect pumps for his penis
that's all I just need like duct tape I
think I literally only need duct tape
now and I win if I can win I will
Oh cruel irony
how you have betrayed me why poop God's
curse you to the hell is Scott Tim ah
okay
I'm all out of time for now I don't have
time to go back and find everything
again and then go so I I there's
probably a ton of stuff in this game
that I have not seen yet whether it's
worth fifteen dollars I will determine
because fifteen dollars usually means at
least a few hours of gameplay but I
don't know if that's gonna be here if I
can win that easily however I may be
totally wrong I may have not have been
close so if you want to see me play this
again let me know in the comments below
let me know what you think of this game
like it's rated positive I can see why
it's got a lot of great aspects of it
and that monsters kind of persistent
although I don't know if he's all that
much of a threat unless I get cornered
so either way thank you all so much for
watching check out the other scary games
that I played in the past and as always
I will see you in the next video
this is like a bad idea good let's do it
again